hey guys Anna and Dave here we did a
couple videos outside that are going on
Anna's channel but then West Hollywood
in the morning there's construction
there's people doing landscaping there's
birds there's a lot of sounds no I feel
like okay you guys have to understand
when we do these videos we do everything
by ourselves we set up the shots by
ourselves we set up the audio everything
they think we have a huge oh yeah people
were bawling okay David who is also the
EP for the Reuben report and also for
the point on TYT Network like he's like
a jack-of-all-trades he puts everything
together yeah you like is always the
problem solver so we're lucky to have
him but yeah yeah Anna right now this
camera that we're talking to you through
is on a table that's on a table that's
on a lunch box that's on a book that's
on a candle literally and that's how
we're getting to you so let's let's do a
little kick him back so I love this
story two of the top astronomers at the
SETI Institute which is the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence at the
University of Berkeley here in
California they told Congress that with
almost a hundred percent probability
there is extraterrestrial life out there
now they were talking more about like
microbial life not aliens not little
green men but I think it's a start and
the fact that they're saying almost 100%
certainty these are scientists these are
the top people I know a lot of people
don't like science don't like what they
hear from scientists but I love this
because I am a big sci-fi ago yeah okay
and like I believe I believe I don't
think you know we've talked about it
before on the main show but like you
know the earth is just a little rock and
it's close to our Sun just enough with
the right elements and all that to gives
life here and here's a good jillion
other stars and soldiers I love it
there's so little that we know about you
know outer space and there's so little
that we know about our own ocean or
oceans I should say so it's kind of
fascinating to know that
like there definitely is life out there
there's no question about it right I
don't believe in like the the made up
Hollywood alien that people talk about
that I do think that there's life
outside of this planet and whenever we
talk about stuff like that I always
think about how dennis kucinich got a
lot of crap for saying that he believes
in aliens but I mean it isn't that
far-fetched you know to think that
there's life outside of Earth there's so
little that we understand yeah do you
think that even if it's not the little
green man but if we found some sort of
intelligent life somewhere that we could
communicate with is there any chance we
wouldn't try to kill each other I mean
if you just think of everything we do on
this planet with people that are beyond
our borders and in our borders like is
there is there any chance that yes I
feel like think what would happen would
be there'd be a little time of
exploration and introspection about the
you know like that and then right after
that it would be like we want what you
have or they want what we have in it's
whoever's more advanced yeah I I think
that people are naturally afraid of what
they don't know and what they don't
understand people don't like change they
don't like anything that's strange so I
think that it'll probably end up in a
really really bad situation but
nonetheless I think it's fascinating to
know that there could be life outside of
our planet and it could be something I
mean I think about that I forget the
name of the company but there's a
company that's going to send or is
trying to send people off to Mars yeah
and they're doing the one-way trip so
one way to Mars which I think is bananas
I would never do that in a million years
I feel like this I literally can't even
get on a roller coaster like yeah puke
on a roller coaster I can't go to Mars
yeah but I think if I could do that not
you know where they knock you out and
they put you to sleep for like 30 years
I would consider it I really would I
really wouldn't you would lose 30 years
of your life but I guess you're sleeping
so you don't age as quickly or something
if I know anything oh
they dress for you if they could keep
you looking young now you can keep you
know your whatever I would be okay right
if I could get there and then try it I
feel like oh I'm so cool I'm cool with
other people doing it for me you you go
out there and explore [ __ ] I'll sit here
no watch how about that alright well do
you guys believe in aliens are we the
only ones here in the universe or is
there more out there let us know in the
comment section